Hello, and welcome to MetaHuman Blueprints in Animation.
My name is Gabriella Crusenio-Cacchus, and I will be your host for this course.
In this course, we will begin by exploring the various components that make up the MetaHuman
Blueprint.
We will go through each component in detail in order to understand the assets associated
with them, such as the skeletal meshes and rigs, the grooms, the LOD sync and MetaHuman
component, rig logic, and the animation blueprints used by all MetaHumans.
From there, we will delve into ways you can animate MetaHumans by creating and fine-tuning
animations using the body and face control rigs, touching upon the IK Retargetor assets
for the body, and facial animation tools that are set up to work with MetaHumans.
We will also take a look at the quality differences between optimized and cinematic MetaHumans,
and then we will wrap up this course with some final recommendations as we make adjustments
to the properties of various MetaHuman components.
And I will also provide you with some tips and resources for you to use as you continue
your work and training with MetaHumans.
This course will be using the project MEH9130055 and a level map should load automatically.
The map is located in the Content Browser under the Courses folder labeled MEH21301
in the Course Maps folder and it is named MEH21301MAP.
In the Course Assets folder, I have included body animations from the Game Animation Sample
project.
In the folder named MHMocap, there is a body and facial animation.
The facial animation has been captured using MetaHuman Animator with an iPhone device,
and the body has been captured with motion capture data and also includes finger data.
In the Source Files folder named 21301AnimAsset, I have also provided a body animation UAsset
file.
If at any point you need to reference the location of the course map, that can be found
at the beginning of the slide deck after the training outline.
Now as we go through this course, you will find that many slides in this presentation
contain a lot of information.
And I will summarize all of that, but if at any point you want to read what is on each
of those slides, feel free to pause and dive right in.
Now let's move on to the first section of this course by exploring the MetaHuman Blueprint
and its components.